Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is
going to be my Marvel Wonder Man video for
the upcoming Disney plus series they just made
a couple big MCU crossover announcements about
the cast so I'll explain where it fits into the
MCU just in general because it's going to take
place inside the MCU version of Hollywood in
the Los Angeles area just like where She-Hulk
takes place it takes place in Los Angeles a lot
of West Coast Avengers happening during Marvel
phase 4. if you're brand new to the channel
I'm actually in the middle of doing episode
videos for She-Hulk be sure to subscribe to get
them all there's a bunch of big stuff coming up
too we have Marvel Disney plus day coming up
really soon they're going to be releasing a
whole bunch of trailers for the upcoming Disney
plus series along with Star Wars trailers too
like we'll probably get a Mandalorian season
3 trailer video of course I will do videos for
all those videos that they release but the real
big announcement you probably saw in your feeds
recently is that wonder man is going to feature
Ben kingsley's Trevor Slattery from the shangshi
movie in Iron Man 3 in the one shot all hail the
king which is kind of like an Iron Man 3 one shot
no sorry don't get it he's supposed to be a main
character during the series the same way that
there's a lot of Wong going on in the She-Hulk
episodes like this week on She-Hulk Wong will
show up and he's got a couple things that he's
doing on the show in addition to the Abomination
plot here's the big connection to Wonder Man like
why he would actually be on the Wonder Man series
because Trevor's backstory is that he's actually
just a failed actor from back in the day and was
hired by Aldrich Killian to play the fake version
of The Mandarin in Iron Man 3 and then during the
one shot all hail the king when Wu's men from the
ten Rings came to capture him with the intention
of killing him and as he explained when we got to
the events of the shung Shi movie he broke into a
scene when they were getting ready to kill him it
was just so ridiculous that all of Wen Wu's men
just started to laugh at him so they spared his
life and just kept him around henceforth as the
Court Jester so to speak putting on performances
for them is not a real pet it's just Dr Singh
that's when I knew if they can teach
those monkeys to act that brilliantly
just imagine what I could bring to the world Wally
was at when was compound he befriended Morris the
captured creature taken from talo that they used
to help them get back into the Tallow Dimension
after the events of that movie if it wasn't clear
when they went back to the main 616 MCU Dimension
because it was in an alternate Dimension later in
the timeline like after a little while has gone
by during the events of the Wonder Man series
presumably they let him go free and he's gone
back to Hollywood to try and get work on a new
show and just happens to be working around the
Wonder Man character on one of these Productions
the other big connection to the shungxi movie is
that the Wonder Man series is going to be done by
the director of the shangshi movie Daniel Cretton
the reason why they would want Trevor specifically
just because the kind of show that wonder man is
going to be they're playing the series as if he
is a Hollywood actor making these types of fake
movies inside the MCU version of Hollywood just
like Wonder man's backstory in the comics in the
comics when he wasn't fighting with the Avengers
he was pretending to be a normal Hollywood actor
making parody movies based on their Adventures as
The Avengers he's such a huge deep cut from the
comics and a lot of the storyline that involves
him like a lot of the connections that he has to
the other Avengers characters like Vision Scarlet
Witch has already happened in the plot so far but
the whole thing with the Nathan Philly and Wonder
Man deleted scenes is that he played a version of
the character in deleted scenes from Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol 2 that's right James Gunn was
going to introduce the character in the MCU
saying that Simon Williams was a movie star
in the MCU using these movie posters from films
he'd done in the past this deleted scene was
meant to take place in the present-day Missouri
scenes when they're showing ego's plan coming
to fruition and he uses all the extra Celestial
energy from Star-Lord to activate his seeds all
over the universe and you see things start to go
crazy with the seeds back in present-day Missouri
near the Dairy Queen where he originally planted
it while this was going on there was meant to be
a Simon Williams film festival happening nearby
James Gunn is from this town in real life his
real-life parents actually cameo in this scene all
the movies that he starred in here the posters are
meant to be big Easter eggs with the comics too
the biggest Easter egg is that he played Iron
Man in a Tony Stark biopic the archon movie post
poster is more of a Conan reference visually but
archon is actually a real Marvel character from
the old school Avengers Comics now he's a very
Conan inspired type of character boconan himself
is actually a different Marvel character within
the Marvel Comics Canon archon also inspired this
series of Arnold schwarzberger who's meant to be
an Arnold Schwarzenegger Easter egg movies based
on the Conan series which the comic book version
of Simon Williams Wonder Man also starred in
the way they portray Wonder Man in the comics is
that his normal Alter Ego type of character like
when he's just walking around normally is Simon
Williams is that he's a Hollywood star like he's
an actual actor so the James Gunn archon movie
poster is like an Easter egg within an Easter
egg within an Easter egg for the Wonder Man
character dead before rival is a movie inspired
by Christopher Nolan's Inception hacks and 2 is
a sequel to the fictional remake of the hacksan
movie by Rob Zombie that appeared in the movie
Super directed by James Gunn the toxic janitor
movie poster obviously a reference to the Toxic
Avenger directed by James Gunn's mentor and and
frequent collaborator Lloyd Kaufman James Gunn
worked for Lloyd Kaufman at troma films when
he first came to Hollywood that was like his
first big Hollywood job and Lloyd Kaufman also
cameos in the Guardians of the Galaxy films the
oh Rebecca movie poster I think is just meant to
be a parody of similar romantic comedies from the
early and mid-2000s maybe also an Easter egg
about the Big Love Triangle that Wonder Man
had with Scarlet Witch Envision during the wand
Division Series there were a couple references
to Wonder Man completely separate from what was
happening with these deleted Guardians of the
Galaxy 2 scenes it was mostly through the white
Vision storyline but also in the opening credits
too during the opening credits when the camera is
panning through all the different rooms and the
floors of the house you see a helmet the helmet
is from the grin Reaper in the comics who was
Wonder Man's brother who attacked the Avengers
after thinking that they were responsible for
the death of his brother but the big twist is that
part of Wonder man's thing is that he always comes
back after he seemingly dies and this time he
just happened to be in a coma later you see the
sword and Tyler Hayward have tried to recreate
Vision resuscitate him using his body parts from
Avengers Infinity war in in the comics originally
The Avengers had to do the same thing they tried
to use the brain patterns from Wonder Man again
to create the same effect that Vision got from
the Soul Stone in the MCU along with the Jarvis
and the Ultron AI programming originally in the
comics when Ultron created Vision he stole Wonder
man's brain patterns that had been backed up by
Hank Pym when they were still trying to save
Wonder man's life and just use the brain waves
to create Visions personality Matrix they kept
bringing Wonder Man back to life periodically
one time King the Conqueror brought him back to
life as part of an evil team he created to fight
The Avengers called the Legion of the unliving
after a few more villains bring him back to
life I think he died like six times in the comics
but each time he was brought back by a different
type of villain that tried to use him to fight
The Avengers eventually he takes control of his
own mind then joins The Avengers then moves to
Hollywood becomes this big star and helps found
the West Coast Avengers so that's where all the
movies that he stars in come from we keep making
jokes about all the West Coast Avengers Easter
eggs in the Disney plus Series in the movies
during Marvel phase four this is like the next
really big one introducing his character legit
he did have a love triangle with Scarlet Witch
after she'd already been married to Vision they
tried to say that wonder man had feelings for
her first because they thought that Vision only
loved Scarlet Witch leading to their marriage
because his brain waves were literally copied
from Wonder mans like his love of Scarlet Witch
came from Wonder man's love of Scarlet Witch very
melodramatic a lot of these classic Marvel Comics
and this gets back to the whole thing with Tyler
Hayward and sword trying to recreate Vision they
tried to do this a couple times in the comics
like vision would be destroyed and the Avengers
would try to recreate him when they're trying
to recreate his body Scarlet Witch goes back to
Wonder Man to ask to provide his brain waves once
again so they can do the same thing and create the
same personality Matrix for vision basically his
powers are kind of like Captain America's Powers
except he's more powerful like Thor or the Hulk
so he's way stronger way more durable than Captain
America and unlike Captain America he has a couple
extra powers on top of that too his real name
is Simon Williams but he got his powers from
Baron Zemo who also gave him the wonderband name
after he found out his company had been rendered
near Bank by Iron Man's company Stark Industries
so thinking that he hated Iron Man Baron Zemo
wanted to use him against Iron Man all the power
that he imbued him with was through an experiment
involving ionic energy so you say Wonder Man's
powers are all based on ionic energy speaking
of which they actually just confirmed that Baron
Zemo is coming back again during the Thunderbolts
movie that Marvel just announced they'll pay off
those Val Madame Hydra Cameo scenes during Falcon
and Winter Soldier the Black Widow movie will also
probably see her in the She-Hulk series recruiting
Abomination next Wonder Man is also supposed to
be stronger than Captain Marvel most of the time
when she's not gone full binary he's been able
to fight the Hulk to a stalemate in his normal
Hulk form he can soak blast of the power Cosmic
from the Silver Surfer he's effectively immortal
like he can come back to life each time he dies
and when he comes back in the comics each time
he seems like he becomes more powerful he can also
fly and he can give off his ionic energy from his
eyes in the form of beams and from his hands he
also shows up a lot in the X-Men Comics too he
gets involved a lot with Rogue so maybe they'll
cross him over with a lot of what's going on in
The Avengers movies when they start doing X-Men
stuff too also he's kind of like the Hollywood
Avenger like the She-Hulk series for instance
takes place in Los Angeles he's probably going to
be another Los angeles-based Avengers character
and remember initially when he debuted in the
comics he debuted as a villain but it was one of
those situations where the villains were trying
to twist his mind against the Avengers and mislead
him so fundamentally he is a good character like I
said what'll probably happen with his character
in the MCU is that they'll balance his powers a
little so that he's not too op like he probably
won't do everything that he does in the comics
but just like they changed a lot of Miss Marvel's
origin story even though there are Easter eggs for
the comic book version of her origin story it'll
probably be the same situation with Wonder Man a
lot of the changes they make are meant to fit
them better with what they've already done in
the MCU so far they haven't announced an actor
yet it probably won't be Nathan Fillion though
the James Gunn Guardians of the Galaxy 2 scenes
will probably just stay deleted scenes technically
those aren't meant to be Canon so like they can
change stuff if they have Easter eggs for related
things everyone post all your reactions to Trevor
being a big part of that Wonder Man series in my
next big video will be my She-Hulk episode 3
video Wong showing up during that one like I
said links for all my She-Hulk episode videos down
in the description everyone click here for my Full
House of the Dragon episode 3 trailer video and
click here for my house of the Dragon episode
2 video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!